we're still inside the city
but it's a war zone it's a battlefield
tanks and heavy armaments
just about everywhere
in the suburbs of harkev the russian
advance has ground to a halt
and in a gruesome display of grit and
intent we were taken to see the bodies
of five dead russian servicemen
the ukrainians had arranged them in the
shape of a zed the identifying mark
placed on russian military vehicles
our uh commanders
told
russians that
you should uh
take back
this borders and they tell that
uh
they don't need it
a ukrainian captain claiming the
russians have refused to repatriate the
bodies
the battle may have stalled but it
certainly isn't over
everyone in this city is sure of that
[Applause]
round one
oh
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
sky news has been unable to verify this
footage but what we can say with
certainty is they inflict horrific
impact
sucking the air out of people's lungs as
they pull in oxygen to generate an
explosion
many felt it was a matter of time before
these bombs were used in ukraine
the destroyed city of mariopol a clear
example russia appears to have no
boundaries
russians have tried to legitimize the
evocation of ukrainian people to russia
and belarus through international
organization where they were blocked and
it has been um recognized and absolutely
a nonsense to evocate people to the
territory of the country who has started
the aggression on ukrainian territory so
now they do it forcefully
i was hugging my mom and trying to hold
back my tears
at least she's somewhat safe here
the rest of the family is in mario
we were talking to my grandma
on the 1st of march
it was her birthday
she was born in 1943
so it would be very sad if she didn't
survive this war as well have you heard
from your family
no
one of my friends has sent me a list of
people being evacuated and he saw that
there was someone with my last name
but
it was just a coincidence not my
religious
you